podemos utilizar la ecuación de enero
para calcular los potenciales de celda y
en este ejercicio vamos a calcular el
potencial de celda para una celda
compuesta de zinc y cobre cuando la
concentración de lyon 5-2 positivo y el
lyon y el ión de cobre 2 positivo ambos
están a una concentración de 1 molar a
25 grados celsius así que estamos
hablando de condiciones estándar justo
aquí verdad y sólo para recordarlo vamos
a ver que tenemos dos semi reacciones
una semi reacción de reducción en donde
tenemos iones de cobre 2 positivo a los
cuales agregamos 2 electrones para
producir cobre sólido y tenemos una red
una semi reacción de oxidación en donde
tenemos que sin sólido que nos produce
iones de 5-2 positivo y 2 electrones
verdad es decir está perdiendo
electrones nuestro zinc sólido por
supuesto si nos fijamos en estos dos
electrones estos dos electrones son
exactamente los mismos que ganaría el
cobre verdad mientras que el zinc pierde
dos electrones son esos mismos
electrones que gana el cobre muy bien
así que realmente cuando cuando hacemos
el balance de esta ecuación estos dos se
cancelan y entonces tenemos aquí la
reacción total o la reacción completa
por supuesto es una reacción de tipo
redox verdad justo esta de aquí es la
reacción completa y además sabemos que
el potencial de es el de estándar es
igual a 1.10 volts verdad simplemente
resulta de agregar o sumar los dos
potenciales anteriores verdad el
potencial de reducción estándar y el
potencial de oxidación estándar muy bien
y todo eso lo hemos cubierto en vídeos
anteriores ahora lo que vamos a ver en
este vídeo es cómo calcular el potencial
de celda utilizando la ecuación
detenerme muy bien así que vamos a
describir la ecuación de nerds que nos
dice esencialmente qué
y que es el potencial de celda es igual
al potencial de celda estándar menos
0.05 92 volts dividido entre n
multiplicado por el logaritmo de q muy
bien ahora vale la pena recordar que son
cada una de estas dos variables verdad
quizás incluso deberíamos decir quienes
también es 0 bueno es 0 es el potencial
estándar estándar de la celda verdad que
tenemos justo aquí y que vale 1.10 volts
entonces estos directamente los podemos
digamos sustituir en esta ecuación
verdad
por otro lado nn es el número de moles
de electrones que son transferidos en la
reacción verdad entonces en este caso
coincide con que n es igual a 2 cierto
y vamos a ponerlo en color azul que es
el cociente de reacción muy bien y sólo
para tener bien claro n en este caso es
igual a 2 y para escribir digamos una
forma más tratable para la variable q el
parámetro q tenemos que pensarlo como si
fuera la k verdad k la constante de
equilibrio verdad pero estamos
utilizando concentraciones que están
fuera del equilibrio verdad así que
pensemos en escribir una expresión
similar pensemos acudíamos q déjenme
hacerlo con el mismo color ok
tenemos aquí y lo pensamos como el
cociente o la división verdad la
concentración de los productos entre la
concentración de los reactivos muy bien
y en realidad no vamos a considerar los
sonidos puros así que esos los vamos a
dejar fuera simplemente vamos a dejar
fuera por ejemplo el cobre sólido y sólo
vamos a considerar el zinc 2 positivo
verdad así que esa sería la
concentración
de nuestros productos sería la
concentración del zinc 2 positivo y eso
lo dividimos entre la concentración de
los reactivos pero vamos a eliminar zinc
sólido y solo nos quedamos con él en la
concentración de cobre 2 positivo nos
dice en el problema que la concentración
de zinc 2 positivo es de 1 molar
mientras que la concentración de cobre 2
positivo también es de 1 molar así que
en realidad el valor de q es exactamente
igual a 1 el cociente de reacción para
este ejemplo es igual a 1 así que vamos
a sustituir todo en la ecuación de next
muy bien vamos a hacerlo un poquito más
abajo entonces el potencial de celda es
exactamente igual al potencial de es el
de estándar que ya vimos que es 1.10
1.10 menos 0.05 92 volts muy bien quizás
voy a omitir por un momento que estamos
hablando de volts dividido entre n que
en este caso es 2 verdad y ahora
multiplicamos por el logaritmo de 1 sin
embargo esto es bastante fácil verdad
porque el logaritmo de 1 es cero así que
toda esta parte en realidad no importa
cuánto vale porque está x 0 y entonces
tenemos que el valor del potencial de
celda es igual a 1.10 menos cero verdad
es decir el valor del potencial de celda
es igual al potencial de celda estándar
que es igual a 1.10 muy bien entonces
esto parece en principio muy
sorprendente que coincidan pero en
realidad esto tiene mucho sentido verdad
porque es 0 que es el potencial de celda
estándar verdad es 0 es 0
este 0 es el voltaje bajo condiciones
estándar y es justamente lo que tenemos
verdad tenemos condiciones estándar
nuestras concentraciones están a una
concentración de 1 molar y además
estamos a 25 grados celsius así que
realmente estamos trabajando con una con
condiciones estándar muy bien y esto
cobras bastante sentido
entonces la ecuación del ernst debería
darnos el potencial de celda como
exactamente igual al potencial de celda
estándar hagamos ahora otro ejercicio
vamos a encontrar el potencial de celdas
nuevamente para una celda de zinc y
cobre pero en esta ocasión la
concentración de lyon 5-2 positivo es de
10 molar muy bien mientras que la
concentración para el cobre 2 positivo
es nuevamente 1 molar y nos encontramos
a 25 grados celsius así que si
intentamos calcular el potencial de
celdas nuevamente podemos utilizar
nuestra ecuación de nery verdad así que
el potencial de celda será igual al
potencial de celda estándar
menos 0.05 92 dividido entre n por el
logaritmo de q donde recordemos que q es
el cociente de reacción así que vamos a
introducir en esta ecuación todo lo que
ya conocemos nosotros por ejemplo
conocemos el potencial de es el de
estándar verdad que es 1.10 verdad así
que simplemente escribimos que el
potencial de celda será 1.10 vamos a
ponerlo con el mismo color será 1 punto
10 - menos 0.05 92 dividido entre n pero
ya habíamos visto que n era exactamente
2 cierto entonces hay que dividir esto
entre 2 y multiplicar por el logaritmo
de q ahora quien sería q en este caso
bueno como vimos en el ejemplo anterior
recordemos que q en realidad se
calculaba como el cociente entre la
concentración de 52 positivo dividido
entre
cobre dos positivos cierto entonces
ahora la concentración de 52 positivo es
de 10 es 10 molar verdad lo tenemos
justo en el inicio del enunciado y la
concentración de cobre 2 positivo es de
1 molar ok entonces sería 10 entre 1 que
es exactamente 10 así que podemos
introducirlo en la ecuación de henares y
que es lo que nos queda bueno pues el
potencial de celda será 1.10 menos 0
punto bueno vamos a simplificar este
número para que sea más fácil de hacer
vamos a vamos a redondear lo a 0.0 60
verdad aunque es una buena es un buen
redondeo entonces esto será 0.0 60
dividido entre 2 que será 0.03 verdad
por el logaritmo de 10 pero el logaritmo
de 10 es 1 verdad así que el potencial
de celda es muy fácil de calcular porque
simplemente será 1 punto 10 - 0.03 y eso
es 1.07 volts muy bien aquí tenemos el
valor del potencial de celda para cuando
las concentraciones están dadas como lo
habíamos indicado anteriormente y de
hecho a mí como me gusta pensar esto es
como el potencial de celda instantáneo
muy bien así que cuando nuestras
concentraciones están en 10 molar para
el 5-2 positivo y 1 molar para el cobre
2 positivo entonces tendremos 1.07 volts
verdad y ese será nuestro potencial de
celda estándar ahora qué pasa con con el
potencial de celda a medida que la
reacción progresa bueno pensemos un
poquito en ello vamos a regresar a
nuestra reacción total o completa
digamos verdad que ocurre cuando hacemos
más
productos bueno pues entonces la
concentración del zinc 2 positivo va a
aumentar verdad la concentración del
zinc 2 positivo va a aumentar ahora bien
para que eso aumente en realidad lo que
ocurre es que estamos perdiendo
reactivos de este lado cierto así que
qué es lo que ocurre con el cobre lo que
ocurre con el cobre 2 positivo es que
disminuye muy bien entonces mientras que
el zinc 2 positivo aumenta el cobre 2
positivo disminuye que ocurre entonces
con el valor de q bueno si por un lado
estamos incrementando el valor de 5 2
positivo y disminuyendo el valor del
cobre de la concentración del cobre 2
positivo eso quiere decir que en total
el valor de q está aumentando
muy bien entonces el valor de q está
aumentando y que le hace eso al
potencial de celda bueno en nuestra
ecuación de nancy verdad si estamos
incrementando q que es lo que le ocurre
a fijémonos eso en eso
en ernst nos digamos pongamos un número
distinto un número más grande para q
digamos que q fuera igual a 100 muy bien
ya estamos ya no vale 10 digamos que
ahora vale 100 verdad entonces como
calculamos el potencial de celda a
partir de la ecuación de next bueno
recordemos nuevamente que esto será y es
igual a 1.10 menos 0.05 92 dividido
entre 2 pero ahora tendremos que
multiplicar por el logaritmo de 100
verdad es decir estamos pensando que hay
ahora más productos a medida que la
reacción
la reacción avanza verdad entonces cuál
es el potencial de celda bueno pues
entonces calculamos esto verdad
simplemente será digamos 1.10 el
potencial de celda será 1.10 fijémonos
que el logaritmo de 100 vale 2 y luego
estamos dividiendo entre 2 entonces
estos se cancelan y sólo nos queda 0.05
92 y esto es aproximadamente
0.06 verdad y esto nos da un total de
1.104 volts muy bien así que fijémonos
en qué es lo que le ocurrió al potencial
de celda si hemos incrementado digamos
déjenme cambiar de color si hemos
incrementado el valor de q antes el
valor de q era 10 y ahora lo hemos
aumentado a 100 lo que le ocurre al
potencial de celda es que fue de 1.07
volts a 1.04 volts verdad así que a
medida que la reacción avanza el valor
de q aumenta y entonces el digamos el
potencial de es el de instantáneo y
disminuye verdad así que mientras que
aumenta mientras que aumenta tenemos que
el valor del potencial de celda
disminuye muy bien y ahora pensemos en
el potencial de celda en el equilibrio
cuál sería el potencial de celda cuando
estamos en el equilibrio
aunque pensemos cuál sería el valor de
esto cuando nos encontramos en
equilibrio entonces si recordamos
digamos la ecuación que nos relaciona el
cambio en la energía libre verdad con el
potencial de celda es el cambio en la
energía libre es igual a menos ene efe x
es verdad entonces cuando estamos en
equilibrio el valor del cambio en la
energía libre es cero verdad entonces si
observamos del lado derecho entonces el
único valor posible para que para que
sea esto cero verdad este producto sea
cero nos dice que tiene que ser igual a
cero así que si el potencial de celda es
igual a cero veamos qué ocurriría si el
potencial de celda es igual a cero
utilizando la ecuación de en ernst
tendríamos que el potencial de es el de
estándar menos 0.05 92 dividido entre n
por el logaritmo natural de toda esta
expresión tendría que ser
al acero pero sabemos que en el
equilibrio verdad en el equilibrio q es
igual a k verdad eso ya lo sabemos
así que si introducimos este valor en
esta ecuación y despejamos tendremos que
el potencial de reducción perdón el
potencial de es el de estándar es igual
a 0.05 92 dividido entre n por el
logaritmo de k muy bien y observemos que
este es justamente la ecuación de la que
hablamos en algún vídeo anterior verdad
el potencial de este es el de estándar
es 0 es igual a 0.05 92 dividido entre n
por el logaritmo de k así que esta es
una forma muy interesante de pensar en
la ecuación de tener verdad la ecuación
dnrt es muy útil para calcular
potenciales de celda cuando tenemos
distintas concentraciones